[Applause]
a hero's welcome for a man who's hoping
to become germany's next leader after a
close-run race all of schultz is
confident he's led the center left
social democrats to their first victory
in parliament elections in more than 16
years
we're a pragmatic party that knows how
to govern we're a confident party that
wants to work to ensure that we have a
better future in germany but we've also
shown that we have what it takes to
govern a country that is unity supported
by everyone and that this was the case i
would like to thank you for that
angela merkel's last minute efforts to
attract support for the conservative
christian democrat candidate amin lashed
seemed to have paid off after lackluster
start to the campaign the cdu and its
bavarian sister party ended up in a
tight race with schultz's social
democrats lush had said he's not happy
with the result but still wants to lead
coalition talks
we will do everything possible to build
a conservative-led government because
germany now needs a future coalition
that modernizes our country
and for the first time in history that
coalition will need three parties to
govern
angela merkel leaves a fragmented
political landscape and while her former
coalition partners the social democrats
are optimistic they will be heading the
next government all options are on the
table and difficult coalition talks lie
ahead
talks not only closely watched in
germany but also in the rest of europe
where many have long looked to angela
merkel for leadership
so a very very long to do list for the
next for the next chancellor and the
difficulty is that they're probably
going to find themselves leading a very
fractious possibly quite incoherent
coalition which could make decision
making even more difficult
this could well mean that europe's
largest economy might be a little less
politically stable than it was in the
past decades staff farsen al jazeera
berlin